[音楽]
ようこそようこそはじめ社長の実験ラボエ
ま久しぶりに兵器の開発と言いますかそう
ですね社長まあね我々もね平和な国とい
つつもいつ木が釣れるかわからないその
ためには用意が必要であるそうというわけ
で今日はですねなんとこちらのフィルム
ケースでロケットを作りますお風呂の入浴
剤で水を入れるとブクブクなるじゃない
ですかあれ飛ばせるんですよバブとかって
炭酸ガスが出るんですよ水に入れそう炭酸
ガスが出るからフィルムケースで圧迫し
たらバンってなるんてねま試しに1個やっ
てみましょうまずは水を入れますちょびっ
とでいいちょっとでいいオケーオッケーで
この後このなんか剤入浴剤を入れ
ます無理
無理いやよくないく本当に怖いいやでもね
意外と待つ
よ本当に怖いんだけど
うわ
こんねた嘘ついたっししょいやいやいやい
待って
み
まさかけないしうお
うおやばマジかというわけでまあねこんな
ね1つをポンってやっても楽しくないんで
こちらに見えると思うんですけどフィルム
ケースすごい量あるんすよまあ1個なんて
しょぼいこと言わずにね全部一気にもう俺
たち2人すごい手が早いもう仕事ができる
んで速攻でバブと水を全部入れてねも全部
一気に発射させてね綺麗な花火を今日は
やろうと思います行く
[音楽]
ぜ長水オッケーす
オッケーよし行こうよし行こ行くよ行くよ
行くよいいよちょっと待って早い早い
ちょっと待ってここうそうそうそう
そうそう早いちょっと早い早いって早いっ
て
メメント2メトメント早い早い早早オオオ
ここ近いよ入れるの早たこれこれ
これ近い近い
[音楽]
くう
まこんな感じ
[音楽]
でまあ
ねうおま僕たちの容量は決していいわけで
はないのでねあのちなみにちなみにたもね
チャンネルがあるのでねぜひ皆さんたの
チャンネル登録してあげてください動画の
下の説明欄にチャンネルがあるので
ありがとう
お
[音楽]
どういう感じでする次もういきなりあれに
完成したものを出てやなる初めは甘いよて
なる俺の方ができるぞと
うお大成功